hola
[Música]
una vez
todos están aquí tiene algo en común
y todos queremos cambiar nuestra
realidad
aquí
[Música]
usted es tomar una decisión y con esa
decisión
qué tal si su nombre los cachos como el
amor de su vida
a visitarme la habilidad
por lo que quiero decir
[Música]
una experiencia para pensar y tomar
decisiones con esa decisión cambiar su
realidad
[Música]
como todos nosotros podemos negociar
como piedras
[Música]
esto lo hacen de una manera pasiva o
activa tomar decisiones y poner
decisiones graves
en realidad
y empezamos ustedes no van a terminar no
nos subimos a instagram
qué pasó entendieron algo y fueron
cambiando su realidad
el 90% de las decisiones que nosotros
tomamos que hacemos nosotros
y por eso todas las decisiones ya en su
vida la lleva
y
todas las bendiciones de este mundo
el otro 10% son decisiones que pasan
fuera de nosotros
y muchas veces está pasando más en el
mundo por la tecnología
[Música]
esta es un examen de matemáticas
por qué
[Música]
y la próxima está
cuando usted es grande para todo el día
me levanto
[Música]
y
entonces pero qué pasa con nosotros
para negociarse mediáticamente
pero qué pasa con nosotros
sobre todo en méxico
tenemos una frase
y todo pasa por algo
si les decimos todo pasa por ahí
investigar
y de repente
cómo
por eso diccionarios y como aprendiz y
adelante
en europa y latinoamérica básicamente
todos decimos todo para saturar proviene
de esta palabra aprender
aprendemos reflexionamos porque pase
humano y seguimos adelante
porque porque las buenas decisiones
vienen de la experiencia y la
experiencia del cliente
de tomar malas decisiones aprendemos a
sí mismo
por aquí méxico no tenemos que hicimos
todo pasan por algo hay que hacer
llega con un montón
no
[Música]
o no
pero sí
entonces qué pasa con ser una persona
mejor porque todo un paso por al
[Música]
ya trabajo
los amigos están todos
[Música]
o no
trabajo porque todo
a veces
porque no aprendemos
[Música]
d
en el trabajo porque ahí tenemos
y ya
[Música]
nosotros estamos
compatibles
porque son decisiones que nosotros
pasivas para nosotros
nosotros
[Música]
publicar se compartió en persona del
mundo
en realidad no estamos mal
la realidad temporal ya tomando lección
ah
vivimos una realidad que no es nuestra
realidad
imagen
un universo entero
con esta falta
yo pienso que yo soy yo no soy lo que tú
piensas que yo soy
yo soy lo que yo pienso que tú piensas
que yo solo
[Música]
después
nosotros hacemos
vivimos la realidad que nos hacen ver
las personas que están a nuestro
alrededor
nuestra mamá
[Música]
para nosotros
un senador un abogado
hijo
[Música]
todos
y tu mente
qué
ah
[Música]
papá
un sueño tengo una oración
[Música]
trabajamos siempre
para el papá
[Música]
y
tú ves eso
y toma sus decisiones por fácil
un cuadrado
tienes en tu navidad
y entonces
se acerca
hoy en día el 80% de las personas que
están trabajando son infelices
porque
es todo
y él
[Música]
por qué
como trabajo
veamos
y tu vida
[Música]
es falta de motivación porque es una
realidad que quieren cambiar
y no saben que es muy factible cambiar
esa realidad
[Música]
en redes sociales
otra cosa
y son tramitadas
[Música]
la tuya
yo pienso que ellos son
yo no soy lo que tú piensas que yo soy
si no son lo que piensas
[Música]
del trabajo
nosotros tenemos un cerebro
esto ya
d
vamos
es un trabajo
es decir 2 millones
que nosotros también hemos evolucionado
y si quiero escribir
no se ha actualizado
[Música]
y vamos caminando por las uñas
de comida
[Música]
de las ordenadas
y llegó
[Música]
bueno
y ahora
[Música]
mira una fruta
y
[Música]
porque no hacemos esto diferente aquí es
el operativo implemente
d
i
[Música]
qué pasa que la motivación es la
motivación es basura sí porque la
motivación nunca está conquistar la
necesita porque la motivación siempre
hace las cosas
y que ustedes les gustan
contradictoriamente
lo que tenemos que hacer
[Música]
más
y cómo voy a cambiar
sobre sus objetivos y a través de
millones
[Música]
de 300 años
d
el santo
[Música]
por qué
tengo una solución
voy a hacer cosas
como por donde hacer 0
me llamo yo
de ella
[Música]
bueno
y negado
no
[Música]
yo no
entonces
[Música]
si me hubiera permitido
para el momento
[Música]
y no
i
para todos
[Música]
vamos
tenemos nosotros
necesitamos que pueda cambiar por
completo
[Música]
número 1
todos tenemos qué
cambiamos la vida de tomar las
decisiones
la números
exactamente cuál es el número 3
[Música]
para cambiar su realidad 1 2 3
[Aplausos]